amo molto lui è possibile tutto questo
tu non puoi non so di quale quello finto
optimo internate inserito stories
oggi facciamo un video particolare mai
fatto in realtà abbiamo anche un po di
paura e dal tempo che io volevo farlo
che un po di paura di quello che si può
vedere in plastica andiamo a reagire ai
big su di me the skaters ma anche dei
fan ci sono dei video su youtube che
hanno fatto su di me in quei dicono cose
su di me oppure li avete già segnalati
da tempo alcuni editato il benevolo al
primo che ho mai visti quindi andiamo a
vederle insieme speriamo bene prima di
stendere una società importante e noi
andiamo a vedere questi video adesso non
andate a cercarvi e insultare le persone
sotto al video
mi raccomando ragazzi non andate
insultarli anche se sono gay intersos
magari diranno qualcosa di terribile non
risultarvi come pietro
video di questo video per riderci sù per
vedere che cosa dicono questi gente su
questi fan come sempre mettetevi comodi
manager un corner lasciato un bel ex
questo video se volete vedere ad
esprimere socialità accedere e
consigliateci quali agli inserimenti
volete che facciamo
nei prossimi video siete pronti sincro
solo di rendere condizioni non di
piangere allora che i ragazzi primo
video allora in pratica per trovarlo e
scritto anita stories e ho messo ordina
per data del caricamento cose non
appaiono solmi video perché sono per
rilevanza popolarità ma mai anno per
dare liberamente se anche voi volete
sbirciare comunque primo video si chiama
slime per anita stories
vediamo se sarà un fallo
[Musica]
purtroppo non si vede bene non si sente
bene
ebbene mosso appelli che ce ne facciamo
una sorpresa che lascia un like e levico
bravissima chissà che col polvere si
dovranno i miei commenti
ecco fatto passiamo il prossimo video
sto video si chiama anni the stories e
bastoni questo mondo anche se con mio
cugino che non si vuole farmi metrico
per ogni opportuno dico perché oggi
attivo perché sottofondo spettegolando
lo ha detto morando no non so perché
qualunque interessava tagli che voglia
che ci siano il matera famosissimo
abbiamo visto pure il boia
e la pena e la pena di morte è stato
riciclato che per kharja 8 poi è
paperoni servizio tutti al cane in
serata la patron ha raccontato storie
horror se non capisco le lasciamo
comunque un like poi magari non lo so se
voi sapete che un video per l'occasione
in questo video
passiamo al prossimo allora qua abbiamo
ciak chat tra anita astori tele di
giorgio che non aiuta sicuramente
conoscete e di un cosa succede in questa
sa che cosa mi dite cosa avrò mai detto
io in questa chat
io dico ciao le cose c'è ciao amica
senti ti volevo chiedere dico io cosa ne
fai una collaborazione con me
picchia collaborazione si fa con i tool
e moses line va bene al video
che formativa collaborazioni domenica va
bene domenica non post spagnoli uniti ok
ciao ciao lui di dante finito così video
allora sorpresa che non ti ho scritto
bello mi chiamo chiese che mette pure
sino a che carina anche lei avrà un
colpo
allora è piccolissimo tra l'altro allora
il video si chiama io odio anita stories
perché mi odia aspettiamo il messaggio
[Musica]
con cattiveria ha detto che la coppia
quindi magari non vedere che video fatto
per vedere se sono simili ovviamente non
sapevo del suo canale però poi vediamo i
suoi video vediamo cos'altro dice
[Musica]
a casa poiché cesura intenzionale non so
perché allora io non so che cosa ho
fatto per bormio dietri tanto ma mi
dispiace dice che moderno che meglio
perché copie suoi video andiamo a vedere
i video questo video a 8x e 203 dislike
sirius
spero che commenti allora nei commenti
dicono non serve giudicare a chi
piacente metterai per commento io
comunque ora vado a vedere i suoi live
che chiamo anita stories io ti schifo il
doppio più scemo forse di tubero che
pokémon comunque penso che questa
bambina non aveva niente da fare se a
noi e forse ha voluto fare un video
stupido naturalmente comunque noi non ci
interessa primogenita stories lui magari
essere famosa fei video più belli
consenso questo il consiglio makiko xvi
volgare lei non conosce neanche come si
fa a copiare allora non me lo aspettavo
tutta questa relazione da online in fans
mi fa piacere che cercate di difendermi
ma mi raccomando
o persona piccola comunque non c'è
bisogno grazie con i fantasmi esistono
squeezable klein paint a sm non lo so
che video pensa che un copiato ma
comunque li lascio un commento
e scrive non fa niente se il canto
carina che caduto pulizzi nota come
reagirà media per vedere ok qua abbiamo
reagisco al video indovina quale reale e
quale è disegnato quindi una reazione
che stiamo reagendo questa reazione ma
la reazione su una reazione
[Musica]
allora prima di tutto come i giardini
scusate sketchup cuccioli di
appuntamenti alcuna proposta da che è
impossibile
tutto questo tu non puoi non stavi quale
quello finto si è giocato il video e
scrivere mi quale quando sito per poter
assestare la sua rete si vede
allora mi dispiace tantissimo ma come ti
chiama star band mi dispiace tantissimo
di non aver visto la terra ti giuro sono
mortificata
per della condanna si guarda si vende
vediamo bungie ha chiesto che non me lo
aspettavo fosse la mente settimane vede
così si arrabbia nuovamente soltanto
perché guardare i paladini troviamo i di
asti che sommando sono scritte a un
cordino vino quindi io dico chi vuole
vedere che c'è anche ciò che non possa
essere ciò che questo segnale ma
soltanto che questa particolare
altrimenti proprio amore come la festa
che prima ha fatto un errore ma che non
si può sentire
[Musica]
rabbia perchè non vedo tutto nero fa
temere che allora facciamo allora questa
cosa seriamente sa benissimo cosa non ha
fatto secondo me perché io che mi sento
che c'è tra bianche non hanno fatto
vivere 0 non è nostra ma il turismo
anch'io sono scesi sta l'errore l'allora
tecnico commento 17 offenda ma ti
consiglio di non essere tanto maestrina
allora io rinnovo le mie scusa per non
aver visto la nutella mi dispiace troppo
così ovvio allora
in questo video si chiama mentre faccio
una smr per voi mia mamma mi rimprovera
flash all'interesse vediamo un po se
volete fare gli sms tra l'altro picozza
può piacere che anche lui più piccolini
mode gsm r
potete stare attenti a non premiare sul
microfono se non fa questi suoi in
maniera non se n'è accorta sogni che
[Musica]
dovete andare a fare i compiti se mai
niente più ma l'ha detto lei
credo dice gradi se mia mamma vi
rimprovera ci sono più troppo bello
dello store agazzi cosa avete capito in
questo video ne lascia un commento che
carina continua fan di aids mer allora
corinne mantineo litiga con anita story
per questo aspetto che sarà molto
interessante per le giuste perché
dovremmo litigare
allora inizio io con un ciao corinne
screen e sanità niente how che è
successa una cosa terribile dico io a
nord rim emilio di qualcosa non capisco
beh io amo molto amo molto lui il
fidanzato di sufi perché per crederci
bene allora io rispondo cosa ma anche
ma no non va bene ma soprattutto veto
sloveno grega una cosa così dal video
del sito sia dal video difesa super che
a memoria lo scopriremo solo nastro
messa pubblica un messaggio insomma
iannace buongiorno su di lui non è gusti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
insomma chi già sa il tuo romanzo hanno
tutti ce l'ha pure tu invece un uomo di
dio
[Musica]
vabbè la nostra storia è il nostro
rapporto finisce qui ciao ciao ciao ciao
nome è finito
non ho detto forse era troppo vincendo
chiunque dato per spacciato
ho molta fantasia di piace immaginare
tipo fanfiction scrivono io seguo una e
l'altra
ciao a tutti e due fibra visti davvero
interessante non vedono l'ora di vedere
il leoncino allora questo video qua
hanno però la cina blair è se vieni the
stories
vediamo chi di queste secondo figlio di
questo canale russo ci sono video che lo
giuro come della stabilità dei vicari
unica stories seguito per farmi testori
che sta portando sulla ora non piacere
ai musica di ge.fi senza energie a tutto
breve che poi ci sono altri perché il
castle rosso scuro partiamo comunque con
il primo video in flash e
divertentissimi provo ma lui dice perché
devi fare le reazioni e lui sta facendo
la reazione al mio video è un buon
controsenso questo è tanti solo facendo
la reazione al suo video alla sua
reazione della mia
adesso non sa manco parlare e riscritte
momento nike a sta annullando iscrizione
che un po perché io volevo peggiore
siccità un videogioco questo io so che
io dovevo tifo toccoli agire sto coso
quelle della nonna sul suo canale un
giorno fa mi sono iscritto io ci sono
riuscito grazie saluto e sapevo che
sarebbe uscito che vieni a storici
[Musica]
[Applauso]
buttarlo sono mezzo miglio cervello
appiccicoso
nel video decisioni di gesto scene la
gente scendesse libro maggiore che io li
chiamerei più comunemente parole su
esposito perché nello sport
riuscirai contenta però sceso maestro
non c'erano insomma corriere è questo un
politico certo se non sono comunque
sarebbe così non è facile per storno
so che la tu assomigli è stato ritrovato
però
chi lo stai zitto zitto vedere che cosa
dice veramente più sempre giore ad un
sacco di parolacce e nero commette un
like it like questa persona non si
merita nessun commento perché ha detto
un sacco di parolacce insultato questo
non va bene
mando il mio video anita storie
stuzzichiamo detto e voglio mandare
questo pdf c'è scritto che senso e sale
fortino mondo perché così chiesto in un
palazzo ciò il mario piccolino click mi
accompagno chiharu mentre the styles e
prete che scrivesse che si iscrivesse il
mio canale che si chiamano perché inter
e telefonia facchetti e poi scrivere
forse la torre dell'elefante cisco nomi
io non faccio i complimenti e mi sono
iscritta a termine l'ascesa con mi piace
poi video
roma 06 set e qualche volta mia madre mi
stringo che stai
51 dopo quell inter non so perché così
di slide si supercar i neonati da sempre
un commento kevin grazie mille per d'oro
massimo video schermo sono questioni si
chiama scherzi come quelli di enit
stories che sono fratello e sorella
vitale pittore torinese alla scuola di
armi che dimostra come mi presto a
seguire the kids ricerche che mi ha mai
in questo scarto quale sempre secondo
fino a pallone perché dio su tutti i
comfort e ciao ciao
allora in pratica dimostrazione di
sostituire la pena con una scarica
giusto
il costo della penna con una canon
script più noti sostituire di toglierlo
ha tradito a jena proprio ieri
[Musica]
l'app è sciolto lotto anche se mangiato
non soltanto io non so chi sei veramente
adesso aspettiamo che le continue cadute
[Musica]
[Applauso]
così sky canale di martina fallacara
l'assoluta reca siete bravissimi e
carini ultimo video è risposta ad alta
astori superiamo i costosissimi positivi
per vedere come giusto che l'ho visto
perché giudicato ma quale veicolo xvi
concreto pagina eric tantissimi
[Musica]
capelli quando a scaricare l'acqua così
[Applauso]
i ragazzi per il consiglio quello che ho
capito la loro piccoli ma devo ammettere
una borsetta giusto online questo video
anche se di febbraio
grazie mille tesoro ok ragazzi questi
anni i video per ora se potete vedere
un'altra parte un altro episodio
lasciato un bel like questo video 6 3 su
10 mian ex farò una seconda forte
potrebbe sapere quale di questi il video
che vi ha scioccato di più o quello che
ci ha fatto ridere di più
e ora che lascia un po cosa caselline su
cui potete cliccare per vedere i
prossimi video nella facciata insieme i
nostri video divertenti click
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao